now here is this change of base law
which you can use quite easily but I'm
going to show you how to derive it it's
very important that you understand the
way this works as we're doing it and I'm
not going to talk it through I'm just
going to let you think about this one
I've kind of explained all of these in
terms of this time and growth metaphor
okay um the reason why I chose those is
because it's easier to understand how to
time your growth relate to each of these
even the whole backwards time thing
which I didn't write down this is a
special case of this right so you're
actually going backwards in time because
you have 1 over B times the size you
were in a future so anyway they all make
sense in time this one's a bit harder so
I want to let you think about it I'm
just gonna show you the algebra it falls
out very very simply and I'll let you
try and work out how you would explain
this in terms of time Pingree okay so
here's our proof for the change of base
law you might even make a little
something for that as it's often the
case the way we're going to approach our
log laws is by using our index laws to
understand them because they're really
two sides of the same coin okay
so if I say I have X which is some
random log okay and what I want to do is
get this in terms of get X in terms of
some other base okay if this is true how
would I rewrite the relationship between
a B and X in index form how would I
rewrite it all right
a it's still the same base isn't it X
that was the subject is the power and
all that's left is been you happy with
that okay now here's a really important
trick that you will take advantage of
much in this topic but even more when we
move into calculus and differentiating
these things I'm gonna take this and I'm
going to take logs of both sides right
so I've got nothing here number here and
they're the same number that's what
equals means so if I say
time taken to grow to this at some rate
should be the same as the time taken to
grow to miss at the same rate does that
make sense
I've gone from two sizes to two times to
get to those sizes so far so good
okay now using the lures we already know
I can I can do something with this right
very simple I can take that X which is
the power I can bring it out the front
so this is actually X log base C okay
okay you can see I'm pretty much there
can't you write all I need to do now is
say well I want X that's what I want
right I make that the subject so I'm
going to divide and now just by
simplifying or I should say substituting
back when I started with I've got my
ball
Oh base a big okay that's it not
complicated we what kinds of things did
we do to get there we had to remember
the relationship between logs and
indices and how they inform each other
we had to use the that power law there
to bring that at the front and then the
rest of it is just manipulation really
all right now before we leave it there's
just one special case of this law that I
want to show you okay at the moment a B
and C are completely random numbers
right they can be anything we like which
is why this is so powerful okay
when you're using this with your
calculator if for instance you want to
work out some sub awkward number like
how long would to take to grow into ten
which clearly is not it's not eight not
16 it's awkward right so you just reach
for your calculator and use whichever
you want because you're in luck C can be
any number you like I'm lazy with
writing so I'm just gonna use the
natural log and that's how you input it
and you'll get a number out okay I'm
just kind of curious let's just quickly
work out what it is
say it again
3.32 which is exactly what you would
expect because it's longer than you'd
take to grow to eight right here just
three but it's not quite as long as
it'll take to get to 60 which is four so
that's why you're between them okay you
see how powerful this time metaphor is
behind its to anything
now the special case I'm interested in
is if a B and C are not random numbers
but if B and C are actually the same
number okay if B and C are the same
number so I'm going to substitute all my
seeds out and replace them with B's
watch what happens I've got the same old
log base a of B over here okay if I
replace all the C's with B's all the C's
of this what do I have on the numerator
I've got log base B of B which we
already we already know what that is
don't we okay and on the denominator I
have log base now this is a see this I'm
gonna replace that B Oh egg okay
now like I said we actually know what
log base B of B is it's one so what does
this mean
log base a of B how long does it take me
to grow to size B if I'm growing at this
rate answer the reciprocal of this let
me give you a quick example of how this
is going to look with numbers because we
just worked one out right if I now flip
those numbers around this is gonna be
one on is that it's going to be the
reciprocal isn't it okay what does this
mean what does this mean
to get to here and this rate will take
me such and such amount of time okay
when I take the reciprocal is this a
short amount of time or a long amount of
time it's very short right I'll get
there like like that why because I'm
going to a smaller number at a faster
rate
this is a really tricky log law it often
it's kind of the one that people forget
okay it's a special case of this one so
if you remember your change of base you
should be able to get to this one but
it's not nearly as obvious as other ones
so if you're if you're booking a log
question you're like I got nowhere to go
precious through your normal log laws
but highlight this one I find students
often forget it even I do sometimes okay